welcome everybody inside the MGM Grand
in Las Vegas that we have all the news
from the ACM Awards on the way and it
was so good yeah it was a wild night but
we start with the big news of the day in
the college bribery scandal Felicity
Huffman pleads guilty and makes a
remarkably candid confession the 56 year
old actress said she had deep regret and
shame over what she had done and
accepted full responsibility adding
quote my daughter knew absolutely
nothing about my actions and in my
misguided and profoundly wrong way I
have betrayed her Felicity also
apologizes to her family but does not
mention her husband actor William H Macy
by name Huffman is accused of paying a
consultant $15,000 to help her elder
daughter cheat on the SAT Huffman
released her statement at noon today a
few minutes earlier the Department of
Justice announced she was among 13
parents who had agreed to plead guilty
to participating in the college
admissions scam the announcement sets
the stage for felicity to agree to a
plea deal the maximum sentence 20 years
in prison the Department of Justice says
plea hearings have not yet been
scheduled by the court
Huffman made her parents in the case
last Wednesday actress Lorie Lachlan who
also appeared in court on Wednesday is
not mentioned in today's announcement by
prosecutors it's gonna be interesting to
see what Lori Loughlin does yeah it's
not only Laurie but it's also her
husband yeah their whole family is in
trouble
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]